(由 TurboScribe.ai 转录。升级到无限制版以移除此消息。) 我是布朗老师，这是
为我二年级语言课录制的视频，
在洪都拉斯科马亚瓜的新冠病毒隔离期间。
大家好，我希望你们所有人都
开开心心，并且勤洗手。
今天我们的目标是拼写常见的动词，
并通过观看幻灯片正确地发音，
以及一起书写这些单词。
有谁知道什么是动词吗？
动词是做事情的词，比如跑、跳、吃。
你们还记得几周前我们玩“老师说”
游戏吗？
记得吗？
你们从“老师说”游戏中学到
了哪些词呢？
这些是我记得的一些。
Play, walk, run, eat, jump, stomp, clap,
drink, read, write, sit, close, open.
你们还知道其他的吗？
还记得更多吗？
让我们再一起练习一些。
我稍后会听听你们怎么发音。
这个活动，你们需要一支铅笔
和一张纸。
观看图片，然后写下你们看到的
图片对应的单词。
当你们理解了这些图片，你们就能够
和你们的同学一起玩一个交流游戏。
同学们。
我们先一起来做这个活动。
好的，第一个是 clap, clap (拍手 pāishǒu),
像这样。
第二个，第二个是 close (关上 guānshang),
close, 像这样。
第三个，第三个是 drink (喝 hē), drink,
drink, drink.
第四个是 eat (吃 chī),
eat, eat, eat.
第五个是 jump (跳 tiào), j-u-m-p.
J-u-m-p, j-u-m-p.
第六个是 open (打开 dǎkāi), o-p, open,
open.
第七个，play (玩 wán / 演奏 yǎnzòu), p-l-a-y.
第八个，第八个是 read (读 dú), r-e
-a-d, read.
第九个，第九个是 run (跑 pǎo), n
-r-u-n.
第十个是 sit (坐 zuò), s-i
-t, 不是 e, 不是 seat, s-i-t,
sit.
第十一个，十一个是 stomp (跺脚 duòjiǎo), s-t,
stomp.
第十二个是 walk (走 zǒu), walk.
这个字母不发音，walk.
最后一个，第十三个，十三个，write (写 xiě), write.
这个字母不发音，write.